AI is ruining YouTube Gone are the days
of genuine creators pouring their hearts
into their videos sharing their
vulnerabilities and forming a deep
connection with their audience
I'm not talking about cases in which
creators use AI to make better content
I'm talking about cases like this from
social media suddenly and this and this
content that's completely generated
using AI from beginning it to end
of course this is most common within the
video essay space but all niches from
Sports compilations and TV show
predictions to Tech news and financial
news have all seen a rise in AI
generated content on one hand it's
insane that such content can be created
completely using AI
everything from the idea generation
script writing and pacing to the voice
over editing and thumbnail
but on the other hand this completely
defeats the entire purpose of YouTube
the chord to YouTube success was not
about high budget Productions like Mr
Beast or a bunch of music videos from
popular singers or flashy displays it
was always the authenticity that stirred
in millions of hearts and Minds from
heart-wrenching Geometry Dash meltdowns
that are too relatable to creators
opening up and sharing their
insecurities and worst moments this has
always been the magic of not just
YouTube but all forms of media even
traditional TV how many people watch
something just because they love a
specific character or hate a specific
character these stories and emotions
filled with creativity diversity and
genuine human connection are what make
visual communication so engaging so
compelling these AI Farms of course try
to replicate this by telling chat GPT to
write stories in a three-act structure
or by discussing big well-known people
but you can usually immediately tell
when a video is created using AI at
least so far
sometimes it's as obvious as the voice
being a robot other times it's a much
more subtle feeling that everything
you're watching is the exact same thing
like a broken record these automation
channels have become masters of
clickbait and manipulating the algorithm
saturating our feeds with low quality
content they basically found a formula
and they stick to it relentlessly
you'll sometimes even see videos with
the exact same titles and thumbnails the
same recycled footage and even the same
pacing and story but whatever gives it
away it's the same distant feeling is
this why two and a half billion people
decided to watch YouTube to see robots
recap random movies that we've never
even heard of or was it to experience
something
the high of conquering an impossible
level
The Wonder of traveling and the pure joy
of passionately uniting around a niche
topic these are the Sparks that ignite a
YouTube's flame in the first place
bringing together billions of people
worldwide and it's these same Sparks
that AI is extinguishing from the
platform but there's an even darker side
to AI content like with any Gold Rush
the people who are actually profiting
are the ones that are selling the
shuffles as thousands of creators are
beings told the idea that they too can
make a million dollars a year by posting
such content so join me as we uncover
the Dark Side of AI generated content
and its impact on the authenticity that
once defined this platform
foreign
completely AI generated content is very
much a new phenomenon chat GPT hasn't
even been around for a year at this
point but unlike AI content itself the
distant feeling associated with this
content isn't new this distant feeling
can be attributed to YouTube automation
which can actually be did it back to
almost the beginning of YouTube itself
it's January 25th 2007. this was the
fateful day that one of the most iconic
channels of all time was created
watchmojo.com these guys are now known
as the OG content Farm but they didn't
start off that way in fact for the first
many years they were just posting simple
tutorials and street-sided interviews
some of these videos did get tens of
thousands of views but most didn't do so
great in fact many of these videos
haven't even crossed the Thousand view
Mark after 15 years clearly this wasn't
working so watch Mojo shifted to making
translation content we're talking
Japanese translations Hebrew
translations Arabic translations Russian
translations and then there was the
random yoga videos as well these videos
got much more consistent views
but it wasn't until September 18 2010
that watch Mojo really cracked the code
with the video top tenant Julia Roberts
movies this got just under a million
views but then watch Mojo went back to
their classic content fall fashion from
inware 332 views fashion show fall
Trends 245 views but then they posted
top 10 Will Smith movies 2.7 million
views and then they did it again and
again and again and again and again each
and every one of these videos we're
pulling in hundreds of thousands if not
millions of views and before you knew it
WatchMojo would become a full-on top 10
Channel putting out thousands upon
thousands of these videos dozens of
which garnered tens of millions of views
I was one of these hundreds of millions
of viewers back in the day but
looking back I couldn't tell you what
exactly made these videos so popular
many of these lists wouldn't even take
an hour to compile and all of the
footage you needed was already out there
so there was nothing particularly
special about these videos but at the
same time there clearly was maybe it was
fans of Will Smith and Angelina Jolie
and all of these other topics wanting to
congregate and reminisce about their
favorite actors or singers best and
worst moments or maybe it was just plain
curiosity what actually are Bruce Lee's
top 10 moments whatever the reason
though these videos were some of the
most popular in the world back in the
early and the mid 2010s as such we saw
dozens and dozens of CopyCat channels
pop up like the richest most amazing top
10 Looper top trending at alux.com Mr
luxury and so much more all of them were
basically just content Farms they would
Outsource the entire video production
process from scripting and voiceovers to
editing and thumbnail design they didn't
have the help of the almighty AI back in
the day but these videos were basically
indeternible from Modern AI videos the
goal wasn't to tell a story or to convey
a message or to make a change the goal
was to just create mindless
entertainment by focusing on quantity
quantity
quantity two three four five uploads
every single day and upload every few
hours most of these videos would do all
right some would do bad but a select few
these would go viral making the entire
operation worth it but almost as quickly
as these channels Rose to fame
they fell off a clan taking a look at
WatchMojo today while they do have a 25
million subscribers their recent videos
don't get any more views than their 2008
and 9 videos it's even worse with the
richest as many of their videos
struggled across even the 10K Mark
despite having 15 million subscribers
some of these channels have even stopped
posting altogether it was official the
days of milking top 10 videos had to
come to an end but this was just in time
for a new style of automation to take
off
foreign
on July 9 2013 over six years after
WatchMojo was created we would see a new
channel enter the space with a rather
hard name
kurz gazot kurz gazat was by no means a
content form in fact they were and still
are the exact opposite only posting once
maybe twice a month their goal with each
video was to break down the most complex
topics you can think of in the most
elegant ways possible using beautiful
animations curse Cassat was truly a
passionate team of illustrators
animators writers researchers and music
producers wanting to create the absolute
best content on the platform and this
showed it signed right through over the
past 10 years they've only posted 193
videos but almost all of these videos
have tens of millions of views each
seeing this it wasn't long until copycat
started entering the scene likely the
most infamous of which being the
infographic show I don't want to back
too much on the infographic show as they
do post some bangers from time to time
like how El Chapo escaped from prison or
how Ted Bundy he was caught also they
have actually been around for longer
than cross Cassat being founded in 2011
but with that being said they very much
operate like a content form given that
they post two to three animated videos
every single day also their animations
and sound design aren't unique and
inspired with each upload like kurz
gazot rather they just use a bunch of
templates and pre-made animations but
the soullessness of the infographic show
was nothing in comparison to what we saw
on November 15
2016. this was the fateful day that five
minute crafts was launched if you've
already erased this channel from your
brain let me give you a warning as I'm
about to give you a painful refresher of
their content
yeah I think that's all that needs to be
shown originally I was gonna show more
examples but I don't want to be
responsible for causing brain damage so
we'll leave it there seriously though I
don't think you can get a single person
in the entire world to argue that five
minute crafts actually makes good
content but man are there videos so
clickable
16 funny hacks that work Magic
21 simple life hacks to look stunning
every day
five minute crafts compilation this
video is a treasure Trove this was their
strategy they were never trying to make
content that moves us or something
their goal was really just to get us to
click in an era where clickbait on
YouTube worked extremely well a couple
of months after a five minute crafts
popped up we saw yet another Channel pop
up bright side bright side was really
just a whole lot more of the same thing
which is not that surprising when you
consider that it's owned by the same
parent company the sole publishing this
whole publishing also owns one two three
go slick slime Sam five earcrafts la la
life actually happened and so many more
these guys are literally the definition
of content form across all of their
channels they post like 50 videos every
single day across 21 languages and who
can blame them for the longest time this
was working phenomenally in fact the
parent company is still the world's
largest YouTube Corporation with over
1.2 billion subscribers on YouTube alone
but more recently things aren't looking
all that great eminent crafts does have
80 million subscribers many of their
recent uploads don't even cross a
hundred thousand views it's even worse
at Brightside where many of their
uploads don't even cross 10 000 views
despite having 44 million subscribers
The infographic show is faring a lot
better but they too have fallen
substantially from their Peak a couple
of years ago you know who hasn't fallen
off though kurskissot to this day they
still put out the best videos they can
and they still get millions of views on
each and every video so clearly the
demand for this content is still
stronger than ever but trying to mass
produce these videos and sensationalize
them didn't work out all that well over
the long term but
what if you added the help of AI
foreign
Ty definitely lowered the barrier for
YouTube automation substantially instead
of paying a scriptwriter a few hundred
dollars you could adjust to get AI to
write a script for free but it wasn't
the ease itself that has led to such an
explosion in AI content brother I
believe the explosion can be attributed
to YouTube gurus to YouTube automation
YouTube automation succeed on YouTube
since the beginning of this year we've
seen a massive influx in the number of
YouTube gurus selling the idea of
getting rich by creating an automated AI
YouTube channel they claim that they
were able to make 30 000 within 30 days
or 8 million within a year and that you
can too all you have to do is sign up
for their free webinar to be honest
these websites look exactly like one of
those Thai Lopez webinars they even have
the timer for crying out loud now let me
say there is some legitimacy to this as
there is with all get rich quick schemes
is it possible to get rich with an
automated YouTube channel sure is it
probable of course not
that's just like Drop Shipping or Amazon
FBA or stock trading possible yes
probable no and just like the Amazon FBA
gurus led to Amazon being flooded with
the garbage from Alibaba the YouTube
automation gurus are leading to YouTube
being flooded with AI garbage
at this point you can go to basically
any Niche you want and you'll find the
same videos with the classic robot voice
clearing his car with lots of cameras
and a bunch of water bottles the stereo
scripts highlighting their achievements
and contributions and the collage of
stock footage the United Kingdom is
currently the world's sixth richest
country now I've got nothing against
these creators if you've made this work
that's awesome but at the same time
that's not the type of content that I
want to be associated with nor is that
the direction that I want to see YouTube
hidden and that's why we're talking face
to face here for the first time in four
years also none of this is to say that
I'm against creators using ai ai is a
phenomenal tool that absolutely should
be leveraged to make the entire
production process more efficient and
put out the best content possible
AI however should it not be used to make
low quality span to milk views
fortunately I don't think AI garbage is
here to stay it's a pretty new trend so
I don't expect it to disappear
immediately in fact it could very well
gain momentum over the next two three
four years but zooming out to 5 or 10
years I think we'll look back at this
time period and the AI spam the same way
that we look back on Vlogs pranks top 10
channels and bright side the bottom line
is that people come here for
authenticity and relatability when AI
adds to that perfect when AI takes away
from that though well I think that
content can only go so far but that's
just what I think I would also argue
that there is a sponsorship problem on
YouTube check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next one